now you gotta
ha i did it that's the first time i've
ever done that with a drone hi i'm rhett
and i'm link and we're guest
correspondents for wired
we review a lot of gadgets on our
channel and today we're excited to try
out the tiniest gadgets that we could
find
[Music]
this appears to be a drone it's a very
tiny drone as a matter of fact
don't
don't turn it on yet i got to read some
uh descriptions about it the sema x20
mini drone is the newest drone upgraded
with a six axis gyro quad roto craft
what one button takeoff and landing an
auto altitude hold this mini drone is
very suitable for indoor playing are any
drone suitable for indoor plane all
right let's read some reviews before we
dig into this thing easiest drone for
beginners super fun it's safe to use
inside to play with my cats five stars
too hard to handle this mini drone for
kids is not easy to handle you just
cannot control it one star i would give
it zero if i could
let's fire this baby
[Applause]
this thing's out of up
hold on okay that turns it yeah now you
gotta
ha i did it that's the first time i've
ever done that with a drone i wanna see
if you can take it out of my hand i'll
take it out of my fingers
boy that's a comedy let me get a little
piece of that action
[Music]
first time i used it i didn't crash it
i'm gonna give it four stars four stars
is great i mean this is a man that's
never played with the drone that wasn't
out of control y254 like he went there
and he came back
four stars
all right what do we have here
it looks to be some sort oh this is one
of those phones before they put screens
on them no this is apparently the xd
wi-fi wireless camera the xd wi-fi
wireless camera is the latest design in
many portable cameras with upgraded
night vision intelligent motion
detection and non-stop recording y'all
you will never miss another important
moment again but
through that yeah like i'm filming you
right now best product i've seen ever
the night vision is incredible you can
really see at night night vision four
stars
i can't tell what it's seen users
seeing in your night areas piece of crap
would not ever recommend waste of money
will not connect to wi-fi the app is
garbage
one star
okay so i'm actually going to connect to
the app we can see the the
the feed here oh gosh oh good do you
really want to show that to the wired
viewers no i don't okay so again we got
a live feed
wirelessly we're not alone it's actually
a pretty good resolution when it's just
like look at that it's us i'm rhett and
i'm link and we're wired guest
correspondents
okay uh
camera of this caliber this small man
this is 72. i think this is 172 dollars
hey it's only 40c now it's cheaper than
i thought it was
[Music]
i don't know i can find no fault with
this this is the perfect camera
five
five stars yeah but you gotta tether it
to a power supply i don't know i it's
working well i really can't complain
about that so if this is what you want i
think you're gonna be happy with it four
stars
[Music]
holy moly so this looks like a smart
speaker this is a mini projector link
enjoy an immersive video and on and
audio experience okay in the comfort of
your own home with the asus zen beam
latte l1 portable projector
latte up to three hours of 720p video
projection and speakers designed by
harman kardon hey that's a big deal i've
heard of them you can transform any room
into a home cinema very impressive the
product is good and the performance is
beyond expectation five stars terrible
purchase who reviewed this pos and gave
it five stars one star
okay so i've wired into this uh computer
which has a video of us making a wired
video from the past and it's an
inception
okay so i had to hold it down oh there
we go oh position that right there whoa
it's like automatically focusing i'm not
doing anything hit the lights i think
we're good guys okay i'm gonna hit play
over here well i gotta say what do we
got for audio here it's pretty the
picture is pretty impressive i think you
have to be really close to it really
appreciate the i mean
it said home cinema you do this as a
home cinema you're going to disappoint
your whole family but if you're like
camping or something
what if you're camping next to somebody
who's like running a generator audio is
leaving something to be desired but i
feel like i'm in the future that i've
got something that doubles as a thermos
that does pretty quality video there i'm
thinking um 200. i think you can get
this for 169.99
what is 439 that's pretty steep
[Music]
i'm super impressed with this thing i
would give it four stars in my limited
experience with it you know did it meet
expectations
it did until it doesn't sound great so
i'm going to give it four stars
[Music]
oh this is a this is a small one this is
so tiny this is like a plastic jewel of
some sort i think if you put it on my
finger it will automatically go wrap
around like a it's like a futuristic
wedding ring it's a mini color sensor
scan any object or surface to find its
paint match match wall colors to top
paint brands yeah we get it we
understand wow no more looking through
old paint trying to figure out which
shade it is possibly the best thing ever
created simply love it five stars piece
of junk totally inaccurate when scanning
a light tan wall it generates a dark
brown result pathetic
one star
let's give this thing a go this is the
second generation so they've improved on
it okay you know what let's see look
you do that and i'll do my brain okay
i'll i'll test green so here it is i'm
going to the next digital app so now you
just put it scan with nyx man put it on
so i'm going to say that this is green
putting it on the green scan with nyx
you're saying that's green it's green so
you take that into the yeah it's sherwin
williams if you will
57a36c but visually it's not really
well no it's
okay well this is hard to tell let's do
another color scan
what are you going to say this one is
blue it made this blue brighter you're
as smart as a little piece of plastic
try my cheek well no try my hand let's
do my hand let's ruin your cheeks do my
forehead do my third eye oh it's a
little greasy up here okay yeah okay
you are so purple oh good gosh
what does this mean it means you're
thanos
i'm guessing 44. you're not getting out
of the gate for less than 111 for this
thing
[Music]
our tests
are not definitive i'm going to give it
the benefit of the doubt i think this is
a smart and fun little thing
and i'm willing to give it a shot i'm
going to give it four stars
so what is this this is called
the mini toothpick concealable titanium
toothpick machine from titanium alloy
material that will last a lifetime works
great as a camping tool multi-use tool
and potentially a weapon i added the
last part about the weapon but i'm just
inferring this on your keychain is
awesome how many times have you left a
restaurant no wood picks available and
have that piece of food stuck in your
teeth and you're on the drive home and
your tongue is working overtime to
dislodge it to no avail i've been there
simple discrete solution thank you you
don't have five stars you don't have to
think people william oh yes
there will be blood seriously it's sharp
you will poke yourself and bleed to
stars
oh my god this is not a toothpick this
is an ice pick what on earth this is
like a way to get yourself out of like a
hostage situation yeah
this is this will get your handcuffs off
man you could totally macgyver this
thing oh i went too high and went
straight into the gum i mean this is a
steel
needle
tip it's like a dental tool i'm getting
a tartar off it's environmentally
friendly you're not throwing anything
away except for what you get out of your
teeth i guess
i usually swallow that i thought did you
just admit to swallowing it well
sometimes i mean it no that's what that
was what it was in there for anyway i
spit it out regardless of where i'm at
i've spit it out at somebody's wedding
before it's so
sharp can we have something to test how
sharp this is
oh okay
you're ready for this look at that they
instantly created okay you hold that and
hold it right there
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna drop
it and see if i can get it to land
oh a bull's eye
look at that
that's crazy can you believe that that
was your tooth you'd be dead try to drop
it from that height into the bull's-eye
i mean that's a i just impressed myself
it's easy
i mean i'm not trying again i got lucky
the first time
it's dangerous i mean if you think about
a toothpick
a wooden one
they're really sharp but they're going
to give it a certain point you could
literally kill somebody this isn't i
don't know about it i don't think you
could fly with it i think that i would
pay
14.99 for this
19.99
23.99 uh making a killing on this thing
[Music]
i'm afraid of this thing of course i'm
not allowed around sharp objects
normally in my life anyway i'm gonna
give it one star listen i'm gonna step
in for the american dental association
here not a representative but i have
been to the dentist we do not endorse
this this is a danger to humankind and
you should stay away from it one storm
sorry
okay that's it that's all five gadgets
they were so little they were so cute
i'm kind of over drones you know i think
drones are over droned i think that the
mini camera could come in handy in spy
situations right i like the projector
i'm just frugal when it comes to like
high ticket items but the more i think
about it the more that i like this
projector i'm gonna use i'm gonna buy
one of those can i can i take that with
me for saying no i'm gonna have
nightmares about that toothpick and the
ways that i accidentally used it on
myself to draw blood stay away from that
toothpick i'm sorry i don't want to be
sued by the company or the american
dental association but stay away from
that toothpick i'm rhett and i'm link
and we're wired correspondents
signing off
[Music]